je suis avatar en fait en lien avec les
énergies de la Vierge Marie les énergies
de Jésus annoncé à de nombreuses
reprises la fin du monde donne lieu à
des manifestations plutôt amusantes
retour en 1960 le frère et man un gourou
prévoit la fin du monde le 14 juillet à
13h45 pour survivre une seule solution
se réfugier au sommet du Mont-Blanc une
heure moins le quart très exactement le
réveil lundi il ne reste plus qu'une
heure à tous les habitants de notre
planète dans une heure si les
prédictions du frère Rayman se réalise
finit plus rien n'existera et vous ne
verrez pas ces images et bien voilà il
est exactement maintenant 13h45 est-ce
que vous entendez derrière ce sont les
trompettes qui célèbrent cette fin du
monde qui aurait dû se passer à ce
moment précis émane a déclaré en
substance j'avoue maître trompé mais
seulement quant à la date pour la fin du
monde prend ta valise et valao sur la
montagne on t'attend en 1975 ce sont les
témoins de Jéhovah qui annoncent que le
pire est à venir le problème c'est que
de dire à quel moment se passeront parce
qu'en fait c'est seulement Jéhovah qui
provoquera ses événements dans les
années 70 les Témoins de Jéhovah ont
l'habitude de se retrouver chaque année
à Colombes cette réunion annuelle de
Colombes est une sorte de fête où l'on
chante et où surtout on écoute de
longues lectures bibliques en attendant
cette fin du monde tant espérée qui
selon les témoins de Jéhovah purifiera
toute la terre allez on part en 1987 la
secte New Age en est persuadé la fin du
monde est imminente et que faut-il faire
pour conjurer les astres se tenir par la
main si ce soir 144 000 possédés du New
Age ne se tiennent pas la main en
poussant un long cri vers le soleil c'en
est fini de notre pauvre planète la fin
du monde et pour 2012 en 1999 c'est au
tour de Paco Rabanne de nous annoncer la
fin du monde et il y a deux ans j'ai eu
des flashs incroyables et je croyais moi
que qu'une comète quelque chose
enflammée allait venir sur Paris et
c'est ce pire que j'ai vu car tous les
prophéties en parlent l'apocalyp se n'a
finalement pas eu lieu certains s'en
réjouissent et organisent un apéro juste
à côté de la boutique du couturier
[Applaudissements]
ne s'écrase pas sur Paris parce que son
orbite ne passe pas au dessus de Paris
donc une raison qu'elle s'écrase faut
s'appelait pas Cora banne pour pour ne
pas savoir cela 11h23
en guise d'apocalypse et de grande
délire de soulagement moi
du monde
en 2012 c'est le petit village de
Bugarach dans l'Aude qui est au centre
de toutes les attentions l'Apocalypse
doit survenir le 21 décembre 2012 seuls
quelques humains doivent être sauvés par
des extraterrestres sur le pic de
Bugarach les journalistes du monde
entier s'y donne rendez-vous ainsi que
des personnages plutôt originaux c'est
de l'autre monde et on va faire la fin
du monde ici moi je suis avatar en fait
en lien avec les énergies de la Vierge
Marie les énergies de Jésus pour
accomplir la régénération les chefs de
l'humanité que ce soit sur terre sous
terre ou dans le cosmos
et les Français dans tout ça la fin du
monde ça leur évoque quoi
c'est à la fin une guerre
mondiale c'est la fin du monde
partout
et puis des robots il y a plus personne
plus d'humain j'ai les hommes sont mis
de côté et c'est des machines qui font
tout à la place des hommes je ne veux
pas partir la première mais je veux pas
rester la dernière
surtout pas fin du monde ou pas certains
investissent dans des bunkers comme ici
aux États-Unis
[Musique]
et si vous voyez ce sujet c'est que la
fin du monde est sûrement pour plus tard
pour la fin du monde prend ta valise et
valao sur la montagne on t'attend
mais dans ta valise une simple chemise
pour la fin du monde